[Music]
we have known for a while that
transformers rise of the beast will be
released in the summer of 2023 and will
be a prequel this came as quite a
surprise as both transformers last night
and bumblebee fell short of financial
expectations so it seems quite bold that
paramount's planning both transformers 8
and transformers 9 as well as an
animated movie and an animated series
the two announced movies along with the
upcoming transformers rise of the beasts
will function as a trilogy while the
animated movie is also slated for
theatrical release the animated series
will be released in nickelodeon later
this year however fans of the movie
series are still likely to look forward
most to stephen keppel jr's blockbuster
transformers rise of the beasts on june
9th 2023
on april 8th the sequel to the highly
successful sonic the hedgehog from 2020
will be released as we recently learned
the sonic movie universe will get a new
edition in form of sonic the hedgehog 3
and a series about the popular character
knuckles this was announced by paramount
at its investors day where sega see o
haroki satomi announced the good news he
said he's looking forward to working
with paramount and further developing
the sonic franchise incidentally the
knuckle series is planned for
paramount's in-house streaming service
paramount plus and is scheduled for
release next year however those
responsible have not yet been able to
say when the third movie will be
released it is also unclear who we will
see in which roles as no content related
information for the future after sonic
the hedgehog 2 is known at this point in
addition to the third sonic movie and
the knuckles series there is other news
during the event paramount also annoys
that the paw patrol sequel paw patrol 2
the mighty movie will also be released
next year in addition a spin-off series
to paw patrol is being produced which
will be released on nickelodeon and
paramount plus so 2023 will be a good
year for sonic the hedgehog and paw
patrol fans of course we'll keep you up
to date on both franchises
in recent days and weeks there has been
a pleasing amount of news about the new
amazon series the lord of the rings the
rings of power after the very first
teaser in january we were able to report
not only a first trailer for the super
bowl but also on brand new images that
amazon itself published apparently
another story from the lord of the rings
universe is now on the horizon
namely a new movie the project is called
the lord of the rings the war of the
rohirrim and apparently revolves around
the well-known inhabitants of the
kingdom of rohan almost 200 years before
the events of the hobbit and the peter
jackson trilogy more specifically the
focus is to be on the then king helm
hammerhead furthermore the construction
of the fortress helms deep the important
setting from the lord of the ring the
two towers will be a major theme the us
magazine variety has already exclusively
published a first image of the planned
movie unfortunately this is still a
concept image and not a real scene from
the movie nevertheless many lord of the
rings fans might feel reminded of the
peter jackson's film trilogy at this
side one reason for this is certainly
the mumma kill on the left side of the
picture because the haradrim once went
into battle on these elephant-like
animals this also suggests that the
conflicts between haradrim and rohirum
will play a major role because the two
human races have an unpleasant common
history in the books by jrr tolkien
however it is rather the dunlandings who
make life difficult for the rohirim
these two peoples are also extremely
suspicious of each other because the
tall dunlandings once lived in the
territory of what was then rohan before
they were driven to don land by the new
inhabitants the rohirim in the lord of
the rings movies they could also already
be seen being recruited by saruman to
destroy rohan the lord of the rings the
war of the rohirim is scheduled for
release in us theaters on april 11th
2024
via twitter army of the dead director
zack snyder announced the cast of his
new movie rebel moon last week this came
as a surprise to some because until now
only star trek beyond star sophia
boutella had been announced snyder who
is not only directing the movie but also
acting as co-writer and producer has
brought his army of the dead colleague
shayhan and 300 author kurt johnsted on
board for the script concerning the
actors the cast now includes charlie
huntman desmond hunzu dunabay brayfisher
jenna malone and skye yang
the story revolves around a human colony
on the far edge of the galaxy it is
increasingly terrorized by the dictator
of belisarius and sees a young
inconspicuous woman as its salvation in
need originally the project was planned
as an official spin-off of star wars but
after some differences the movie is now
appearing on netflix under the name
rebel moon however we shouldn't expect a
release soon as this netflix movie is
supposed to lay a foundation for a big
franchise and is being produced
especially lavishly for this reason as
soon as we know more you will of course
find out on our website and in our
weekly news
released in 2007 the game bioshock and
its two successors are among the
absolute classics of the gaming world
which is now waiting for the announced
fourth part of the franchise following
bioshock infinite which was released in
2013 but that's not all fans can look
forward to soon netflix has announced
its own movie adaption of bioshock via
its twitter profile netflix geeked apart
from the quote rapture founder andrew
ryan posted there and the announcement
of the collaboration with game developer
take 2 there is unfortunately no
information on the cast or plot of the
project yet while adaptions of
successful games are seen rather
critically in the gaming community the
moon among bioshock fans seems to be
quite positive after the failed attempt
of a movie adaption by pirates of the
caribbean director gore verbinski we can
only hope that the netflix adaption will
not fail this time due to the high
budget a definite start date for
bioshock is not yet known
amazon currently has its hands full with
its upcoming the lord of the rings
series as deadline recently found out
the next big project is now in the
pipeline it's a series called blade
runner
for which all kinds of creative minds
and producers are being sought ridley
scott already caused a stir at the end
of 2020 when he announced that the pilot
episode had already been written now the
production is to go ahead as quickly as
possible because this project allegedly
has the highest priority from the
streaming giant in terms of content
blade runner 2099 is to be a spin-off of
danny villeneuve's highly acclaimed
feature film blade runner 2049 and
according to the title is to be set 50
years after the 2017 movie the franchise
is based on the dystopian novel do
androids dream of electric sheep by
philip k dick considered by many to be
the co-founder of the cyberpunk genre in
fact the blade runner series has also
existed on the big screen for several
decades the origin lies in the original
movie blade runner from 1982 which by
the way was directed by the current
series producer ridley scott after
several spin-offs of the original movie
last year's series blade runner black
lotus is the latest offshoot of the
franchise though not in live action as
with blade runner 2099 but as an anime
in addition to ridley scott lead writer
silke luisa has also been signed on and
is now waiting to welcome more writers
for the script due to the still rather
early production phase we unfortunately
don't yet know when exactly blade runner
2099 will be released but considering
the ongoing search for people
responsible for the amazon project it
will still take a while longer
in 2009 the star trek reboot was
released by producer jj abrams now it
was also he who announced a new star
trek movie at paramount investors day
after mainly new series have appeared so
far we can now finally expect his sequel
after more than 6 years since the last
movie star trek beyond the movie will be
shot at the end of this year and will
bring various characters from the
predecessor back to the big screen
among them according to the report from
variety are chris pine simon peck zoe
zaldana call urban joncho and zachary
kinto in addition adams let it be known
that there will also be some new
characters and they are working on
several other stories star trek iv will
be the movie of one division director
matt shackman there's still no
information about the content even an
original plan appearance of chris
hemsworth as the father of james kirk is
still not confirmed the story is said to
be based on the original script by
sierra burch's elusive writer lindsay
beer and captain marvel writer geneva
robertson dwarit which is currently
still being revised by avatar to writer
josh friedman and one division writer
cameron squires there also talks of a
star trek movie by quentin tarantino and
one by no holly but there is still no
start date for these star trek four on
the other hand is scheduled for release
next december 2023
that's it for the news this week we
recommend the first trailer for the lord
of the rings the rings of power which
provides first impressions of the new
amazon series also don't miss the second
trailer for doctor strange and the
mulderers of madness
[Music]
you